ça faisait un petit moment que j'ai pas
parlé de mondes connectés et fait donc
vous parler aujourd'hui de 7 mondes
connectés là c'est là honorent magic
watch 2 alors vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que je sais pas d'arguments dans
les commentaires si vous le saviez oui
ou non mais au nord c'est une marque qui
appartient à huawei qui fait partie du
groupe huawei est là pour le coup c'est
vraiment flagrant encore plus parce que
c'était au nord magic 2 ressemble trait
pour trait à la voix enrouée watch gt2
qu'aujourd'hui on va se faire un petit
tour complet de la montre je vais vous
montrer ce qu'on peut faire avec je vais
vous dire c'est intéressant et vous
devez bien évidemment les points
positifs mais également les points
négatifs et voir au final c'est cette
route au nord magic watch 2 est fait
pour vous alors pas du tout confinement
je lui ai demandé de m'envoyer vos
vidéos voir comment ça se passait chez
vous pouvez m'envoyer votre vidéo à
l'adresse qui s'affiche ici amour @ me
cheuvreux point fr est aujourd'hui la
vidéo du jour
pourquoi monsieur grains de pluie les
confins de la côte d'ivoire en afrique
de l'ouest
merci pour cette chaîne ça fait vraiment
plaisir de jeu le dire faire plaisir en
retrait plutôt que c'est très agréable
de suivre
j'aime bien la façon dont les retours
sont faits sur des nouveaux produits et
tous voilà donc là c'est pas ce à quoi
ressemble l'afrique particulièrement la
ville d'abidjan je me suis juste isolé
en brousse histoire de m'oxygéner un peu
par 72,2 convient d'en profiter des
derniers instants de liberté voilà donc
dont courage à tous ceux qui sont
confinés à bientôt
merci à toi pour ta vidéo on va donc
maintenant parler de la dernière monde
honorent la première chose que j'ai
envie de vous montrer cette packaging
parce que ça n'a pas changé grand chose
par rapport à la vôtre mais ça monte
entre qui est assez intéressant c'est le
soin qu'a apporté au nord à sa montre
packaging à honor magic 2 hélas si vous
regardez bien ces modèles 46 mm parce
qu'il existe deux tacles la montre
normalement elles se situent juste ici
vous voyez ailleurs la marque du cadran
elle est positionnée comme s'attaque à
l'intérieur le branding honor qui situe
là et là vous voyez qu'une petite
languette vous êtes invités à venir à
l'ouvrir vous avez toujours votre contre
ici toujours les découper vous allez sur
notre petit compartiment dans lequel
vous allez retrouver vocale pour venir
la recharge est que vous allez c'est
bien au chaud ici plus une petite
documentation sauf que au nord a
vraiment voulu faire quelque chose de
premium et pour le coup c'est assez
réussi donc
cela avait quelque chose de positif on
va voir ça continue comme ça le deuxième
point c'est le truc le plus important
est bien saisir et l'aspect global le
design moi le premier truc que j'aime
cette montre là c'est que vous avez un
vrai bracelet pour venir régler à votre
poignet extrêmement facilement la tenue
est bien là il existe différents types
de bracelets lassé du silicone bien pour
aller nager et pour faire du sport vous
avez un cadran en acier inoxydable
l'idée c'est que ça va venir là les gsa
surtout leur beaucoup plus résistante
aux rayures
donc vous voyez leur nez le monde bien
fini de boutons sur le côté et si on se
rapproche comme ça vous pouvez le voir
vous avez le petit liseré rouge qui vous
indiquent le bouton principal
le deuxième ne l'a pas personnellement
je pense à efficace c'est esthétique on
a une jolie montre aura ici à l'écran
amoled de 4 pouces le tactile est
extrêmement réactif vous pouvez venir
régler bien évidemment votre fond
d'écran
il y en a plusieurs ça jouait très
regardé personnellement j'ai mis
courants d'air et vous pouvez venir
régler la luminosité la charge
automatique
mais je veux régler mais à 5 et là ça
fait tout de suite beaucoup beaucoup
plus dont vous pouvez l'utiliser très
facilement en extérieur c'est donc un
écran qui sera extrêmement lisible
quelles que soient les conditions ça
mais comme ça elle s'éteint je bouge le
poignet aux samoa
elle s'inquiète tout de suite et si vous
voulez laisser allumée en permanence h
messier me contorsionner s'applique
extrêmement ésident vous aller dans les
paramètres et tout en haut là vous avez
ça vous laisser être allumées et votre
nom sera allumée en permanence ce qui
fait que quels que soient les choses que
vous allez faire vous aurez toujours une
honte à lui mais elle va jamais c'est un
haut niveau d'autonomie forcément ça va
descendre drastiquement je vous parle
d'autonomie dans quelques instants c'est
un point très intéressant justement
mais si vous voulez toujours voir
l'heure qu'il est quelle que soit la
position de votre bras si vous voulez
partager avec quelqu'un en permanence et
bien vous pouvez le faire
et puisque je vous parlais de rapidité
la montre est fluide sachant que c'est
vraiment bien et notamment par rapport à
ce que j'ai pu tester sur une ancienne
montre de huawei
comme l ont fait exactement dans le même
moule n'ont pas dû purement
technologique et bien il ya eu un gap
entre la première version est la
deuxième version 6 plus fluide ici vous
avez un kirin a un qui va lui octroyer
un peu plus de performances par rapport
à ce que vous aviez avant à la
différence de la première génération que
j'ai pu tester sur la monte de huawei ou
vous ne pouviez strictement rien stocker
intérieur magnifique et je trouvais ça
un petit peu dommage
ici huawei huawei honor a corrigé le tir
en ajoutant du stockage on nous annonce
4 gigas de mémoire pour venir stocker
alors attention ces 4 gigas oui mais en
réalité vous ne disposez pas de 4 gigas
vous disposez de 2 gigas convient non
quand même divisée par deux degiv
à promettre quoi pour mettre de la
musique alors bon normalement de gila
musique vous pouvez quand même voir
venir tranquillement et justement fond
sur un sujet un peu qui fâchent parce
que je vous parle de mettre de la
musique éviter de tomber il faut
vraiment je change de tabourets mais
comme on en profite non je ne peux pas
c'est compliqué et cui regardez un peu
la lambada dessus mais pour l'instant
été encore donc si vous voulez tomber
vous inquiétez pas justement il ya un
truc qui me chiffonne un petit peu avec
cette montre effectivement pouvait
mettre de la musique je vous montrais en
quelques instants vous avez une
application c'est l'application huawei
sentez vous allez utiliser pour venir
connecter votre smartphone quel qu'il
soit à votre montre dont vous pouvez
venir importé de la musique sur le
principe c'est plutôt bien mais si vous
êtes comme moi en utilisateurs de
spotify avec un abonnement premium et
ben vous ne pouvez pas le terme
tout simplement parce que cette montre
ne vous permet absolument pas de venir
télécharger une quelconque application
et là je ne comprends pas je comprends
pas parce que c'est vraiment un point de
gérer une équipe alors c'est pas qu'on
doit écouter absolument mais je
comprends pas je viens en cas d'usagé on
va y réfléchir on va se dire ok voilà ce
que nous on peut proposer un instant
test d'une première version
je peux le comprendre mais sur une
nouvelle version deuxième version qui a
été longtemps après pourquoi est-ce que
huawei nous avons intégré la possibilité
d'avoir des applications tierces
est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas de contrat pour
pouvoir avoir les licences pouvoir
utiliser en tout cas les affections
qu'on puisse les télécharger c'est
complètement possible
on connaît la problématique aujourd'hui
de huawei qui à l'érection la galerie
qu'ils travaillent plus avec google donc
il se peut qu'ils aient un petit
problème là-dessus parle de problème sur
mon tabouret il se peut qu'ils aient un
petit problème là dessus mais voyez pour
moi typiquement que bizarre ça pose
problème parce que si je télécharge de
la musique
j'ai un fichier mp3 que je veux
l'importer dans le monde je peux le
faire mais surtout les autres
abonnements est ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui sur youtube musique ceux du
desert du spotify quelles que soient les
services que vous utilisez les bienvenus
pouvait pas le faire
le seul service avec elle a priori vous
semblez pouvoir travailler c'est au
wawel musique mais au-delà de ça on est
quand même un peu limité sa ferme un peu
et ça bloque en tout cas pour l'usl de
la montre parce que pourquoi avoir du
stockage si ce n'est pas pour venir
stocker de la musique d'autant plus que
là vous pourrez avoir votre montre de
peu à côté des écouteurs bluetooth
directement partir courir sans votre
smartphone pour se connecter pour moi
y'a il ya un truc qui manque est
d'autant plus que cette montre elle est
vraiment vraiment mais vraiment marqué
sportif parce que oui si on parle pas
aux sportifs voient pas qui on parle
alors avant de vous montrer comment ça
marche au niveau des sportifs
un petit peu les boutons le premier
bouton vous permet de revenir à l'écran
principal ou alors tenir doit vider dans
votre menu vous voyez vous commencez
tout de suite pas entraînement là
clairement au fait un gros focus sur le
sport on record d'entraînement statut
d'entraînement rythme cardiaque history
d'activité donc on prend effectivement
des gens qui bougent
une fois qu'ils ont bougé ils doivent se
reposer et pour voir s'ils vont bien on
peut gérer aussi le stress et faire des
exercices respiratoires donc là on est
dans tout ce qui lie activité physique
ensuite journal d'appels des contacts la
fameuse musique dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure le baromètre si vous
allez marcher en montagne vous voulez
savoir à quelle latitude vous situer
votre boussole pour venir vous repérer
lorsque des grandes séances extérieur
notification la météo pour savoir s'il
est bon est ce que vous allez courir le
chronomètre pour compter votre score le
minuteur pour vous dire à part un petit
compte à rebours une alarme pour vous
dire je me réveille le matin pour aller
faire du sport volant pour vous dire
allez c'est reparti recouvrir et une
lampe torche pour sur quelque chose
lorsqu un peu plus obscurité détecter le
téléphone tu les paramètres donc voyez
ici on est quand même extrêmement
orientée sport mise à part vous donnez
leur donner votre rythme cardiaque et
pouvoir écouter un peu de musique mais
bon c'est pas extrêmement simple et bien
vous n'avez pas beaucoup d'usagés que
vous allez avoir ex est montré pour une
montre collectés seront c'est un peu
dommage donc c'est un vrai compagnon
pour les sportifs mais au bled ça bon et
encore vous n'êtes pas tout montrer ça
c'est le premier bouton le deuxième
bouton c'est un espèce de raccourcis les
miens attribue une application ici par
exemple et bien par défaut c'est
l'application d'entraînement bah tiens
puisqu'on est là je vous montrez vous
avez la course l'idée avec 13 courent
marchent courent basique course
intermédiaire course légère courbe
brûlage de graisse basique brûlage de
graisse basique encore et vous avez des
leçons avec différents niveaux donc ça
c'est quand même plutôt bien pour les
personnes qui veulent vraiment ce que
c'est des objectifs commence en
extérieur j'ai mon petit gps
parce que oui effectivement bien j'étais
à l'intérieur du châssis vachement bien
courses à l'intérieur sur un petit tapis
appuyez sur le bouton du bas tac
j'appuie sur le bouton du doigt et là
elle me parle alors ça c'est bien mais
elle part uniquement en anglais elle ne
parle pas en français et a priori elle
pas aussi vous parlant chinois pour voir
qu'on a une montre qui complètement en
français pourquoi une parole en langue
française ça aussi c'est un peu un point
notre compréhension je peux venir arrêté
mettant pose carrément look est comme ça
je peux toucher l'écran il peut rien se
passer montrent elles sont si je
l'écouté de la musique mode l'atsa pas
grand chose à aller moi j'arrête marche
en extérieur marche en intérieur
cyclisme en extérieur cyclisme en
intérieur nage en intérieur nage en
extérieur randonnée la course cross
country le triathlon
elliptique rameurs haute vous appuyez up
sur un petit bouton à côté vous définir
un bon objectif vous rappel vous pouvez
définir le temps les calories vous avez
une option bouton bas et vous venez
l'assigner à l'application de vous
voulez pouvait venir naviguer dans vos
cadres envoyer votre rythme cardiaque en
fonction de la journée votre niveau de
stress en fonction de la journée ici il
fait quand même plutôt beau votre
musique et vos objectifs quotidiens donc
avoir une jolie montre c'est bien mais
faut-il encore qu'elle puisse durer dans
le temps au nord lorsque vous allez sur
leur site vous donne une autonomie
jusqu'à 14 jours 14 jours sans venir
recharger votre montre moi j'arrive pas
exactement 14 jours vous la gardez une
semaine une bonne semaine en fonction de
vos besoins
si vous êtes tout le temps à l'extérieur
avec le gps si vous écouter beaucoup de
musique d'autonomie va baisser mais ce
qu'il faut compter à peu près en moyenne
là dessus c'est une semaine vous ne vous
posez pas la question ça c'est souvent
un des points négatifs et jusque venir
reproché aux montres c'est qu'il faut la
recharger tous les jours tous les deux
jours et certaines montres cherche
vraiment améliorer ça en proposant des
options vous allez pouvoir venir coacher
décoché est bien ici comme vous avez une
montre qui ne va pas trop communiquer
avec vos smartphones parce qu'il n'ya
pas de l'application il ya juste les
notifications qui vont venir passer et
bien vous allez économiser de la
batterie et pour la recharger
complètement il vous faudra un petit peu
moins de deux heures le point positif
c'est que votre mental marche assez bien
sur un os que se rendre grâce à
l'application alors là je monte sur un
android
ici j'ai un p 40 pro je vais dans wawel
ce qu'on appelle dans l'application
santé comme vous voulez aller traduit
qui si je vais dans appareils devraient
donc j'ai ma montre le nombre de palau
mon dernier exercice le nombre de kilos
calorique j'ai brûlé la distance
parcourue
je peux choisir le cadre d'un autre
venir activer désactiver ou et roussely
d'ailleurs c'est un truc qui m'intéresse
vont être ou slip l'application de
sommeil parce qu'on vous dit que votre
montre est capable de reconnaître les
phases de sommeil profond de sommeil
léger et même de mouvements rapides
oculaire et tout ça grâce à votre montre
alors j'imagine que ça dépend bien
évidemment de vos mouvements ça me
paraît difficile à venir vérifier sans
aller voir un spécialiste du sommeil
qu'il ya vous analysez mais en tout cas
a priori elle peut le faire toute la
partie musique ça c'est intéressant
revenir gérer l'aisne
dick je clique sur ajouté et là on
propose deux choses soit depuis mon
appareil donc la musique que j'ai dans
mon téléphone quand je vais dans mon
appareil ça va me trouver je pense
quelques petite sonnerie fouillant n'est
pas à l'intérieur
sinon dans l'application musique ça
m'ouvre l'application musique de huawei
et là je peux ajouter les morceaux que
j'ai dans mon application musique donc
c'est utiliser l'application au wawel
musique et que je deviens télécharger ma
musique
eh bien je pourrais l'avoir mais une
fois le plus c'est uniquement dans ma
musique et on est un peu bloquée puisque
les utilisateurs des autres applications
de musique et bien ne pourront pas la
boire et ça c'est dommage
vous avez ensuite une notification
pouvait venir activer désactiver pour
voir toutes les applications qui vont
pouvoir venir communiquer directement
avec votre montre le rapport de la météo
donc ça c'est l'application android il
n'existe également sur un os elle
s'appelle donc huawei santé je les
paliers là dessus parce qu'elle est liée
sur l'autre mais voyez le principe ça
marche vraiment de la même manière autre
point positif pour cette montre vous
avez un micro mais vous avez également
haut parleurs pouvoir passer un coup de
fil
donc si quelqu'un vous appelle vous
pouvez décrocher par les la personne
vous entendre alors la qualité du son
est pas complètement dingos sera pas
aussi bien que sur votre smartphone
néanmoins c'est possible ça fait tap que
c'est bien ça ces points positifs
maintenant le point négatif c'est que
vous n'avez absolument aucune commande
vocale pour venir répondre à un sms il
répondre à un message comme vous
pourriez faire sur d'autres montres à la
concurrence lorsque vous recevez un sms
par exemple il faudra donc prendre vos
smartphones venir taper votre cns pour
envoyer avec la montre c'est strictement
impossible
et encore il faut savoir que le micro et
le haut par là pour venir passer des
coups de fil c'est uniquement sur la
version 46 mm on a donc ici à faire un
très joli montre à destination des
sportifs pouvaient les énergies avec
jusqu'à 50 mètres alors vous n'irez pas
nager jusqu'à 50 mètres est ce que ça
vous montrez vous pouvez aller nager
dans une piscine vous pourrez nager dans
la mer vous pouvez vous laver les mains
pour aller vous doucher avec et c'est
une man que vous trouvez au tarif d'un
de base elle coûtait 199 euros 90 vous
pouvez trouver en ce moment à 169 euros
90 pour vous donner une vision globale
de ce projet c'est vraiment une jolie
montre c'est une belle progression de la
part de honor ou huawei mais on bute
encore sur un truc on bute vraiment sur
cette partie musique fluide vraiment sur
le fait de ne pas avoir d' application
qui se mirent importé dedans pareil sur
la partie entraînement vous avez beau
avoir des textes écrits en français la
voix sera en anglais est assez dommage
encore un truc il faut vraiment que au
nord ouest avant ce aille plus loin pour
que leur demande puisse vraiment séduire
un plus large public pour que je puisse
venir vous l'a conseillé au delà des
usages toujours mon tout de suite si
vous êtes sportif que la musique c'est
pas votre truc et que les applications
vous empêchez voulait vraiment une
montre que pro sport c'est une très
bonne montée sur tout ce qui est
vraiment bien c'est l'autonomie
l'écran est très cool l'autonomie est
très bonne si vous oubliez toute la
partie applicative et toute la partie
musique pouvait y aller voilà contraire
je vous la conseille pas voilà pour le
talent de cette non dites moi ce que
vous en pensez vous en bas aux
commentaires comment vous l'approuvez 7
au nord n'a dit quoique ce2 sur ce je
vous embrasse vous rendez vous dès
demain
n'hésitez pas à venir tout ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire des
bisous et à demain
ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et